Du findest es immer und überall.
Guten Abend. Stössel, Stadtpolizei.
- Guten Abend.
Fuck.
Es war für uns
als Minderjährige einfacher,
an Gras zu kommen als an Alkohol.
Weil es illegal ist,
ist es noch verlockender.
Einfach etwas anständig.
Ich bin auch anständig zu dir.
Mal einen Gang runterschalten.
Wir wollten es einfach ausprobieren
und wissen, wie es sich anfühlt.
Du kannst mit Gras
deine eigene Welt aufbauen.
Ich wollte nichts mehr machen.
Ich dachte: Scheisse, bekomme ich
voll die Psychose? Bin ich am Ende?
Dass mit mir etwas nicht stimmt,
dass ich psychotisch bin,
ist mir geblieben.
Meine Kollegen
haben meinen Arsch gerettet.
Hey, Bro, ich hab gerade keine Zeit
zum Telefonieren. Peace, Bro.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Leise Hip-Hop-Beats aus dem Handy *
Die kurzen Haare
sind so viel geiler.
Scheiss aufs Wachsenlassen, Alter.
War schon crazy,
als damals die ersten begannen,
unter der Woche zu kiffen.
Kiffen wurde halt
auch mega zum Hype.
Brutal, Alter.
Zuerst war's Biersaufen,
aber als die ersten anfingen
zu smoken, war's nur noch das.
Am Anfang sagten wir
"Alter, die Scheiss-Kiffer".
Und in der 3. Sek schrieben sie uns:
"Woher habt ihr Gras?".
Wenn alle kiffen,
kifft man halt auch.
Nicht mal aus Gruppenzwang.
Es ist normal, gehört dazu.
Wie Chaim und Till
rauchen viele ihren ersten Joint
bereits im Alter
von 13 oder 14 Jahren.
Es war so geil.
Kiffen ist ein Jugendphänomen.
Seit Jahren
belegen Schweizer Jugendliche
europaweit einen Spitzenplatz
beim Cannabis-Konsum.
Ich hatte keine Erfahrungen
mit irgendetwas,
das das Bewusstsein beeinflusst.
Es hat mich einfach mega
interessiert, wie das wohl ist.
Wenn man noch so jung ist - wir
machten uns nicht viele Gedanken.
Es ging ums Zusammensein,
nicht darum, high zu werden.
Wir waren noch mega enthusiastisch,
freuten uns aufs Kiffen.
"Was passiert dann wohl?"
* Hip-Hop-Musik, Gelächter *
Das Video kannte ich nicht.
Heieiei, das ist ja Hardcore.
Was?
- ... Shisha.
* Ein Mädchen kichert. *
Heieiei.
(Mädchen) Hey, was läuft?
Es waren auch Mädchen dabei.
Eigentlich recht viele.
Wir waren Spezielle.
Das ist ein Foto
vom ersten Mal kiffen.
"So cool, wir haben fett Gras."
Das Foto zeigt das Gras und den
Joint und ich schrieb drunter:
"amnesia is lifestyle".
Boah, katastrophal. Ganz schlimm.
Ach du Scheisse. Diese Pose!
Wieso? Ich sehe es nicht ein.
Heute raucht Till nur noch legales
Gras ohne psychoaktive Substanzen.
Es ist an jedem Kiosk erhältlich.
Das Einzige, was ich wusste, war:
Vom Kiffen
kann man eine Psychose bekommen.
Ich hatte aber keine Ahnung,
was das ist.
Ich wusste nur, es ist nicht toll.
Die meisten Jugendlichen
haben den Konsum im Griff.
Bei einigen wenigen jedoch
kann der Cannabis-Konsum
zu grossen Problemen führen.
Ein bisschen Angst war sicher dabei,
aber nie eine überwältigende
oder grosse.
Martin war 20 Jahre alt, als er
in der Psychiatrischen Klinik ankam.
Eben hatte er die Lehre
als Polymechaniker
und die Berufsmatura abgeschlossen.
Ich liess mich einweisen
und wurde im Notfall aufgenommen.
Das war
eine sehr angespannte Situation.
Es war nicht wie
bei einem Beinbruch, wo man denkt:
"Danke, dass ihr für mich da seid."
Das Gefühl war mehr:
"Ihr wollt mich
ja irgendwie abschieben."
Martin nimmt die Realität verändert
wahr, leidet unter Wahnvorstellungen.
Cannabis
löste bei Martin eine Psychose aus.
Voraussetzung dafür
ist eine Veranlagung.
Ich wusste nicht,
dass ich dazu eine Veranlagung habe.
Ich hätte es mir aber nach
dem ersten Konsum denken können,
weil mich das total
aus der Bahn geworfen hat.
Ich konnte
keine klaren Gedanken mehr fassen.
* Er stöhnt. *
Als ich 15 war, habe ich angefangen,
also zum ersten Mal gekifft.
Der Konsum hat dann
konstant zugenommen.
Wir konsumierten so viel, bis wir
uns nicht mehr bewegen konnten.
Das war ziemlich exzessiv.
Ich versuchte,
meine Emotionen wegzurauchen.
Weil ...
Wenn man 15 ist, beginnt man,
die Welt zu entdecken.
Man beginnt die Welt zu entdecken,
sich über Politik, Internationales,
den Klimawandel zu informieren.
Man entwickelt ein Bewusstsein,
sodass man denkt:
"Hey,
wofür mache ich meine Ausbildung?"
"Wenn ich damit rechnen muss,
dass ich in 30 Jahren
die Luft auf diesem Planeten
nicht mehr atmen kann?"
Dann flüchtet man sich
in die Drogen.
Da bin ich sicher nicht der Einzige,
der findet:
"Hey, wir haben keine Zukunft mehr,
also machen wir noch Party,
solange wir noch können."
Kurz vor meiner Psychose
habe ich auf Hasch gewechselt,
also ich konsumierte
fast nur noch Hasch,
der um ein paar Prozent stärker ist
als Cannabis.
Dann rauchte ich wirklich exzessiv.
* Nervöse Musik *
Wenn man so eine Riesenmenge
konsumiert, hört das nicht mehr auf.
Dann wird das Hirn die ganze Zeit
mit diesem THC beschossen.
Das führt einfach dazu, dass man
von den Reizen überflutet wird.
Angsteinflössend ist, dass man das
Gefühl hat, dieser Zustand bleibe.
* Drängende Musik *
Wir hatten Spass. Viel Spass.
Wir haben konsumiert,
Musik gehört, gelacht.
Ich wusste, dass es verboten ist.
Der Vater, der konsumiert
und seinen Rausch auslebt ...
Das hat mich so fasziniert.
Mein Vater darf konsumieren,
aber er sagt mir, es sei gefährlich,
ich dürfe das nicht konsumieren,
es schädige mega.
Das reizte mich, weil ich nicht
wusste, ob das wirklich so ist.
Was da dreht, ist das Gras.
Und da drin wird es geschnitten,
mit dem Motor zusammen.
Meine Eltern
wiesen mich schon darauf hin,
dass es für meinen Kopf
ziemlich schädlich sein kann.
Dass ich vergesslicher werde
und mir nichts merken kann.
Das war mit der Zeit auch der Fall.
Aber das war mir in dem Moment egal.
Mir war es wichtiger,
Teil der Kollegengruppe zu sein,
cool zu sein.
Ich wollte den Stress zu Hause,
den Stress in der Schule vergessen,
lockerer werden
und nicht immer verkrampft sein.
Ich habe mir damit
etwas Freiheit genommen.
Aus der Freiheit wurde Abhängigkeit.
Während der sechs Jahre Konsum
flog Sven von der Schule,
dann aus der Lehre.
Der Konsum dominierte den Alltag.
Bis heute fehlt
die Unterstützung von der Familie.
Seit einem halben Jahr
ist Sven in einem Cannabis-
Entzugsprogramm im Zürcher Oberland.
Es ist anstrengend,
jeden Morgen aufzustehen.
Aber ich versuche es.
Im Neuthal
ist sein Tagesablauf strukturiert.
Therapie ist zentral.
Ich weiss, wenn ich liegenbleibe,
ist der ganze nächste Tag versaut.
Wenn ich den ganzen Tag
herumgelegen bin,
habe ich am Abend
viel zu viel Energie übrig.
Ja.
Dann schaffe ich es am Abend nicht,
einzuschlafen.
Dann bin ich die ganze Nacht wach
und das überträgt sich
auf den nächsten Tag.
Dann bin ich an dem Tag
auch schlecht gelaunt.
Dann dreht sich die Spirale abwärts.
Du siehst oder spürst am Morgen:
Kein Bock, keine Lust.
Dann bekomme ich ein schlechtes
Gewissen, wenn ich im Bett liege.
Das finde ich voll in Ordnung.
Und über dich ärgerst du dich auch?
In dem Moment nicht, nein.
- Aber kommt das irgendwann?
Ja, leider.
- Leider?
Ich kann mir
einfach nicht vorstellen,
immer aufstehen zu müssen
und arbeiten zu müssen.
Welche Alternative hast du?
- Eben keine.
Wie viele Leute
haben eine Alternative?
Wenige, gar keine.
Für die meisten Leute
ist das die Realität.
Ja.
Und:
Wenn du willst, dass dir
dein Leben lang welche reinreden,
das Sozialamt oder ein Vormund,
dann darfst du so weitermachen.
Wenn du das nicht willst,
musst du das ändern.
Ich möchte ja mal
eigenständig leben.
Das finde ich auch toll.
Ich gehe durchs ganze Haus,
schaue die Waschbecken an
und putze sie,
wenn sie schmutzig sind.
Damit es gut aussieht.
Ich fülle auch die Handtücher nach.
Inwiefern unterscheidet sich
dein Morgen hier im Neuthal
von dem,
den du früher zu Hause hattest?
Struktur und ...
Ich bin Teil von etwas.
Aber es ist auch anstrengend.
Wieso?
Wenn man mal nicht das erfüllt,
was erwartet wird,
gibt es meist Diskussionen.
Nach einem halben Jahr Therapie
denkt Sven darüber nach,
seine abgebrochene Berufsausbildung
nachzuholen.
Was stellst du dir für nachher vor?
Kleinkindbetreuer oder ...
... in einem Kleiderwarengeschäft.
Also Hauptsache etwas Soziales,
mit Menschen.
Hast du schon ein Ziel,
was du weiter machen könntest?
Ja, mit Schnuppern anfangen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich habe früher nie geraucht,
nur Cannabis konsumiert.
Seit ich hier bin, habe ich
eine Suchtverlagerung gesucht.
Was machst du heute, wenn du
das Gefühl hast, du brauchst es?
Skillen.
- Was heisst das?
Sport machen, Gitarre spielen,
eine Ablenkung finden.
Oder fertigdenken z.B.
Mir überlegen, was passieren könnte,
wenn ich so weit gehe,
wenn ich wieder ins alte Muster
fallen würde. Das v.a.
Was denkst du,
warum bist du in eine Sucht gekommen?
Ich hatte halt ...
nicht so einfache Momente.
Ich wurde in der Schule
z.B. gemobbt, ziemlich extrem sogar.
Und ich war von Grund auf psychisch
nicht ganz auf der Höhe,
kann man sagen,
und konnte mir deswegen
gewisse Gefühle nicht geben.
Der Ko... der Konsum
hat das alles für mich erledigt.
Ich konnte alles
vergessen und verdrängen.
Ich musste mich nicht mehr darum
kümmern, wie sehr ich mich hasse.
Weil es einfach okay war.
Wenn ich mich einsam fühlte,
waren die Drogen da.
Was ist denn jetzt da,
wenn es dir nicht so gut geht?
Was ist an diese Stelle getreten?
Ich.
Ich bin an diese Stelle getreten.
Das lerne ich jetzt.
Und auch Geduld mit mir selber.
Die gewinnst du langsam?
Ja, die habe ich. Die habe ich.
Ich musste sie mir aber erkämpfen.
Ich bin hier eingetreten
ins Cannabisprogramm
und sagte mir:
Ich bleibe zwei Monate,
aber in der ersten Woche haue ich eh
schon ab, weil ich es nicht schaffe.
Ich merkte aber recht schnell - also
hatte es eigentlich schon gewusst -
dass ich mehr Zeit brauche.
Ich wollte sie mir aber nicht geben.
Ich merkte aber,
wenn ich sie mir nicht gebe,
komme ich hier raus und es geht
genau gleich weiter.
Das ist für mich keine Option.
Das wäre Selbstmord.
Ja.
* Angespannte, tickende Musik *
Johanna? Ah, du bist Karina.
Ähm ... was macht ihr, wo seid ihr?
Sag diesem Ben noch mal,
er soll sagen, was bei uns läuft.
Als ich angefangen habe, auszugehen,
hat auch genau das angefangen.
Wenn ein Joint herumgeht,
wird er dir,
auch wenn die Leute wissen,
dass du nicht rauchst,
meist trotzdem angeboten.
Wirklichen Druck gibt es nicht. Es
ist eher ... Es ist halt lustiger.
Safe. Ruf mich einfach noch mal an.
Bei uns ist es fast so,
dass die Frauen dafür mehr smoken.
Gut, ich habe das Gefühl, die Frauen
haben es besser unter Kontrolle.
Perfekt. Okay, ciao ciao.
Jungs kiffen deutlich mehr
als Mädchen
und leiden auch häufiger
an Folge-Erscheinungen.
Hier ist noch
etwas Alkoholfreies dabei.
Den Stoff beschaffen sich
die Jugendlichen über Freunde,
Bekannte oder Kleindealer.
Ihr Hilfsmittel: das Handy.
Hallo, hallo.
- Hallo. Freches T-Shirt.
Ich glaube, du kannst in einen Park
gehen oder gehst am Abend aus,
und du findest es immer, überall.
Die Allerwenigsten, die kiffen,
dealen auch.
Bist du sicher?
Die meisten, die hier am Tisch
kiffen, haben schon mal gedealt
oder haben es sich überlegt.
* Lachen *
Aber ich glaube,
so durch den Standardkonsum
kommst du eigentlich nicht
in Berührung mit dem Schwarzmarkt,
ausser mit deinem Dealer.
Zum Teil gibt es auf den Strassen
Gras, das extrem stark ist.
Wirklich extrem stark.
Den Dealern kann man nie so recht
vertrauen, denen geht's ums Geld.
Wenn's ums Geld geht,
kann man nicht wirklich darauf
vertrauen, was sie übers Gras sagen.
Über dem Schwarzmarkt
geraten Jugendliche
immer wieder an gefährlichen Stoff.
Informationszentren in Grossstädten
bieten zwar neuerdings
Cannabis-Tests an,
Doch oft bleibt der Konsum
mit Risiken verbunden.
Oft ist es so, dass die Eltern
das Leben, das man im Ausgang führt
oder mit seinen Kollegen,
gar nicht richtig kennen
oder gar nicht richtig mitbekommen.
Man kann so was gut verstecken.
(Mann über Funk) Verstanden.
Hier ist die Zentrale, Platz 1.
Raffi, antworten.
Ja, super. Danke fürs Ausholen.
Yves Stössel und Roger Christen
von der Jugendpolizei Winterthur
im Einsatz am Wochenende.
Ihre Arbeit ist eine Mischung
zwischen Repression und Prävention.
Wenn irgendwo jemand ist, dann ...
- Da unten oder bei der Treppe, ja.
Cannabis ist die meistkonsumierte
illegale Droge in der Schweiz.
Die Strafverfolgung aber
ist knifflig.
Guten Abend miteinander.
Stadtpolizei.
Wir machen eine Kontrolle.
Den Joint könnt ihr gleich
ausdrücken und mal da hinlegen.
Gerne einen Ausweis.
Danke schön. Aus Winterthur?
- (Voiceover) Nein.
Wo denn?
Haben Sie noch mehr dabei?
- Ja, voll.
Sie sind volljährig?
- Ja, 20.
Hat noch jemand was dabei,
das er nicht dabei haben sollte?
(Mehrere) Nein.
- Danke. Sie können zu mir kommen.
Sind wir clean?
- Zumindest nicht gesucht, ja.
Habt ihr auch noch irgendwas dabei,
wie euer Freund?
Nein, ich kiffe nicht.
Der Besitz ist straffrei,
aber der Konsum kostet 100 Fr.
Ja, ist logisch.
100 Fr. Busse. Ich schicke
den Einzahlungsschein per Post.
Eingeschrieben oder normal?
- Normal.
Können Sie den
auch per Mail schicken?
Nein, das geht nicht.
Sonst kommen Sie kurz mit zum Auto,
dann fülle ich ihn aus
und kann Ihnen die Busse
in die Hand drücken.- Ja, fix.
Ist das gut?
- Ja, fix.
Okay. Sonst haben Sie nichts dabei?
- Nein, voll nicht.
Warten Sie kurz hier.
Wie viel ist das noch, 2 g?
- Ungefähr.
Hätte ich nicht geraucht,
wäre es mir auch weggenommen worden?
Ja.
Aber der Besitz
ist nicht unter Strafe gestellt,
aber weil es
eine Vorbereitungshandlung ist,
wenn man es mit sich trägt,
wird es trotzdem sichergestellt.
Wir versuchen wirklich auch,
aufzuklären,
nicht nur repressiv zu arbeiten.
Wir versuchen,
beiden Seiten gerecht zu werden.
Vielen ist nicht bewusst,
dass es immer noch verboten ist.
Viele denken, es sei legal.
Auch weil der Besitz bis 10 g
straffrei ist.
Aber der Konsum ist halt
nach wie vor verboten.
Das ist fast ein wenig
ein Widerspruch.
Das ist so.
Es ist für uns
auch schwierig handzuhaben.
Und es ist schwierig
für Jugendliche, für Konsumenten,
da noch durchzublicken.
Dort unter der Treppe.
* Dumpfe, drängende Musik *
* Hip-Hop-Song aus dem Handy:
"Traube Minze" von Luciano *
# Jeden Tag hustlen für mein Geld.
# KaDeWe, Designer mit mei'm Babe.
# ... a mir verbiigoot.
# ... i so viu verschiedne Fium
wie dä De Niro.
Bro, es gibt Leute, die haben
voll Flashs, so abgefuckte Träume.
Bei mir war das nicht nur ein Traum,
es war auch Nachtwandeln.
Alter, bist du nachtgewandelt,
ohne Shit?
Ja, ich bin dann von oben ...
- Nur, wenn du gekifft hast?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich war beim Arzt
und die Eltern waren dabei,
da wollte ich nicht sagen,
dass ich gekifft hatte.
Ich ging runter zum Zimmer meiner
Eltern und hämmerte an die Tür.
Damn.
- Ich fing auch an zu heulen.
Während du gepennt hast?
Ich bekam es nicht mit,
mein Vater erzählte es mir dann.
Okay, das ist schon ein Flash.
Damn. Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Das war dann der Anfang des Wandels,
um nicht mehr zu smoken.
Till ging noch
in die Sekundarschule,
als auch er in eine Krise geriet:
Sein Vater erkrankte an Krebs.
Wenn du psychisch schon labil bist,
tut kiffen nicht unbedingt gut.
Ja, klar.
- Das weiss man ja eigentlich auch.
Aber in dem Moment denkt man halt:
"Es wird schon gut gehen."
Man denkt gar nicht daran.
- Ja, logisch.
Wir hatten
noch nicht so viel Erfahrung.
Aber ich merkte schon,
dass ich immer der war,
der am meisten irgendwo anders war.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Zu Hause konnte Till
seinen Konsum verheimlichen.
Bis ihn psychische Auswirkungen
quälten.
Das macht lowkey
ein wenig Schuldgefühle.
Als ich dann so
in der 2., 3. Sek etwas mehr kiffte
und Anfangs Gymi ziemlich
viel mehr kiffte als sonst,
sagte ich mir irgendwann:
"So, jetzt ist wirklich etwas los."
Wir sassen an deinem Tisch und ...
Bro, dein Scheiss-Licht.
Ich ass Corn Flakes und das Licht
war voll auf meinen Händen,
aber mein Kopf war im Schatten.
Boah. Ich war voll fokussiert
auf meine Hände und das Essen.
Gleichzeitig hat alles
angefangen zu flimmern.
Ich schaute meine Hände an
und hielt sie nicht für meine.
Als ich sie bewegte, hatte ich das
Gefühl, das mache ich nicht selbst.
Das Gefühl, nicht bei sich zu sein,
nicht in seinem Körper zu sein ...
Man kann es nicht wirklich
beschreiben, es ist sehr schwer.
Ich sah wohl
wie der grösste Schizophrene aus.
Ich sass ungefähr so da
und checkte gar nichts mehr.
Wirklich nichts mehr.
Ich hatte diese Situation noch nie.
Darum ist es etwas anderes,
so was sehr Starkes zu sehen.
Erst später,
als er wieder zu sich kam,
konnte man mit ihm darüber reden.
Aber selber wusste er
nicht wirklich, was los war.
(Seufzend) Alter.
Ein guter Freund von mir kannte -
ausgelöst durch andere Substanzen,
würde ich mal sagen -
diese Depersonalisierung schon.
Er war so was wie der Drogenguru,
was das Ganze anging.
Er erzählte mir, dass er das kennt.
Dadurch hatte ich überhaupt erst
eine Ahnung
von einer Depersonalisierung.
Also ging ich zum Psychiater, der
das von anderen Fällen her kannte.
Es half total, eine Person zu haben,
die mir sagte,
dass ich das wirklich habe.
Es war auch überraschend,
dass Gras so was Gravierendes
auslösen kann.
Von Gras hatte ich das halt
einfach nicht gewusst.
Darum war der Überraschungseffekt
schon sehr gross.
Ich musste akzeptieren,
dass ich nicht mehr kiffen kann.
Das war schon recht schwer.
Dann versuchte ich mich schon
etwas mehr um ihn zu kümmern
und ihn davon abzuhalten,
wieder zu kiffen.
Martin erhöhte seinen Cannabis-Konsum
im Verlauf der Jahre stetig.
Ich habe meine Grenzen
klar überschritten.
Man verliert die Kontrolle über sich
selbst und hat den Eindruck,
man werde von einem Chip oder einer
digitalen Implantation gesteuert.
Ich fühlte mich von Polizei
und Sicherheitsdiensten verfolgt.
Ich ging davon aus, dass mir
ein Verbrechen angehängt wird,
das ich nicht begangen habe,
dass ich als Drogendealer
hingestellt werde.
Irgendwelche skurrilen Dinge.
Dass ich vor Gericht
oder ins Gefängnis komme.
Das war eine grosse Angst,
die mich verfolgte.
* Dumpfe, elektronische Klänge *
Auch Martins Freunde kümmerten sich.
Sie leiteten die Einweisung
in die Klinik in die Wege.
Jedes Mal, als ich dich sah,
hatte ich das Gefühl,
dass es noch schlimmer ist
oder spezieller.
Jedes Mal
machte ich mir mehr Sorgen.
Darum war es mir auch sehr wichtig,
dass du endlich
professionelle Hilfe bekommst.
Meine Angst war mehr,
dass dir was passiert,
weil du was machst,
das man sonst nicht macht -
dass du aus dem Fenster kletterst
oder so und stürzt.
Meine erste Angst war nicht Suizid,
sondern ...
Ein Unfall.
- Ja, ein tödlicher Unfall.
In dieser Phase dachte ich
nie darüber nach, mich umzubringen,
weil ich zu lebhaft war.
Es ging eher
in die gegenteilige Richtung.
Ich wollte das Maximum erleben,
gleichzeitig, auf einmal.
Als wir herausfinden wollten,
was mit dir los sein könnte,
füllten wir einen Fragebogen aus,
auf dem stand:
"Plötzlich hat unser Freund das
Gefühl, er spreche andere Sprachen."
Genau, das trifft zu.
"Plötzlich fühlt sich unser Freund
verfolgt." Genau, das trifft zu.
Das sind eigentlich
so klassische Merkmale.
Wenn man während einer psychotischen
Phase etwas kommunizieren will,
ist das verdammt schwierig.
Man hat zu viele Gedanken,
die man in einen Satz bündeln will.
Mehrere Gedankengänge
laufen gleichzeitig ab.
Und dann haben die noch irgendwelche
Interaktionen untereinander.
Und dann ...
Es ist so spannend,
wie du das sagst.
Genau so fühlte es sich an,
wenn man dir damals zuhörte.
Als ob du uns drei, vier Geschichten
gleichzeitig hättest erzählen wollen
und wir kannten
vielleicht eine davon.
Da ist es sehr schwierig zu folgen.
Da hat sich herausgestellt,
dass er aus allen Normen fällt.
Dass er den Job verliert,
sich mit den Eltern nicht versteht,
aus der WG geschmissen wird.
Es gab auch Freunde, die sagten:
"Mit dir chille ich nicht mehr."
Er stand quasi mit Nichts da.
Ja.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Ich bin gerade etwas emotional.
Wieder ...
Ich bin froh, dass ich aus der Welt,
in der ich war,
wieder herausgeholt wurde.
Dort ist es einsam, so allein.
- Darüber sind wir alle froh.
(Irgendwie möchte ich das alles
zurückgeben, was ich bekommen habe.)
(Es hat mir wirklich gezeigt,
dass wir ein Freundeskreis sind,
in dem man zueinander schaut,
sich umeinander kümmert,
egal, was passiert.)
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Kann ich dir diese Sachen geben?
Oder was machst du gerade?
* Er räuspert sich. *
An den Servietten.
Ich glaube,
das musst du noch einweichen.
Hmm, ja.
Mein Alltag bestand eigentlich
nur aus Konsumieren -
hauptsächlich zu Hause.
Ich hatte keinen Kontakt mehr
zu Freunden.
Mir war nur wichtig, zu konsumieren,
nach draussen zu gehen,
um Drogen zu verteilen,
und wieder nach Hause zu kommen.
Montags gibt es
bei uns einen Hausputz.
Da bin ich Chef und muss schauen,
ob alle richtig geputzt haben.
Und falls nicht,
muss ich das ansprechen.
Du hast riesige Fortschritte
gemacht, seit du hier bist.
Ich bin ja schon eine Weile hier.
Ich habe seinen Verlauf
vom Eintritt bis heute miterlebt.
Dazwischen liegen Welten.
Es ist echt ... Ja, das ist so.
Du hast extreme Fortschritte
gemacht.
Du bist aus dir herausgekommen,
schaust hin.
Manchmal ist es schwer,
und man hat keine Lust.
Das geht mir auch so.
Trotzdem bleibst du dran,
bist noch da und kämpfst weiter.
Ich denke gerade an die Zeit zurück.
Es war richtig hart.
Ich trat mit einer Unsicherheit ein,
ob ich wirklich
mit dem Konsum aufhöre.
In diesem Moment
war mir einfach wichtig,
ein Dach über dem Kopf
und Essen zu haben.
Ich sehe noch vor mir,
wie er auf der Bank sass.
Du hast dich total verkrochen.
Extrem so ...
Mega eingeschüchtert und ängstlich.
Ja, es ist ... Oder nicht?
Doch, schon.
- Eben.
Und du hattest grosse Probleme,
zu reden, dich zu öffnen.
Wir hatten zwar von Anfang an
einen guten Draht zueinander,
aber ansonsten
hattest du extreme Probleme,
über deine Gefühle zu sprechen,
dir deine Gefühle und Schwächen
einzugestehen.
Das war zuvor unmöglich.
Dazwischen liegen Welten.
Es war gerade schön, das zu hören.
Ich sehe das nicht
als selbstverständlich,
dass man so etwas sagt.
* Sanfte Musik *
Till hat seine Krise
heute überwunden.
Was soll ich helfen?
- Du kannst die Teller bringen.
Wie soll ich es sagen?
Ich war etwas enttäuscht,
weil der ältere Sohn
schon ziemlich viel kiffte.
Ich hatte eigentlich das Gefühl,
Till findet das auch blöd.
Denn wir hatten immer
sehr viele Diskussionen,
und es gab Stress.
Ich dachte,
er sei irgendwie gescheiter.
* Till prustet vor Lachen. *
Das kannst du
doch nicht gescheiter nennen.
Mit dumm sein hat das nichts zu tun.
Nein, ich hatte bloss gehofft,
du würdest nicht kiffen.
Als ich das bemerkt habe,
war ich enttäuscht und dachte:
"Oh nein, jetzt wiederholt sich
die ganze Geschichte noch einmal."
Es wünscht sich wohl keine Mutter,
dass ihr Sohn kifft.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch
lange nicht wirklich bemerkt,
wie viel du kiffst.
Du hast es eigentlich
überhaupt nicht bemerkt.
Doch, schon. Du hast es ja ...
In der 2. Sek wusstest du es nicht.
Ja.
Du hast es erst
etwa ab der 3. Sek bemerkt.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, ich hätte
alles in meiner Macht gemacht.
Und dass ich nicht die Kontrolle
über alles haben kann.
Ja.
- Das ist schon ein blödes Gefühl.
Ich habe aber auch nicht viel
erzählt, was sonst abgeht.
Nein, du hast nicht viel erzählt.
Ich habe schon gefragt, aber du
hast keine Antwort darauf gegeben.
Das ist auch irgendwie verständlich.
Ich denke, es war eine Reaktion,
in einer Zeit,
in der auch Papa starb.
Einfach ... Ja ...
Ja. Gut, jetzt weisst du zwar mehr,
aber weniger besorgt bist du nicht.
Oder schon?
Doch, schon weniger.
- Ja? Okay.
* Bedrückende, pulsierende Klänge *
Guten Abend. Stössel, Stadtpolizei.
Dürfte ich Ihren Ausweis sehen?
(Frau) Ich habe keinen dabei.
- Kein Ausweis?
Danke schön.
Sie mit der schwarzen Jacke
standen zuvor hier.
Das gehört nicht mir.
- Wem dann?
Ich weiss es nicht.
- Sie waren mit der Hand am Mischen.
Das gehört trotzdem nicht mir.
- Aber Sie hatten es bei sich.
Das ist Besitz,
Sie hatten es bei sich.
Bringen Sie kurz Ihre Bauchtasche?
Ich schaue mir das an.
- Ist gut.
Kommen Sie zu mir.
Ist noch etwas in den Hosentaschen?
- Nein.
Haben Sie etwas anderes dabei?
Hatten Sie schon mal
mit der Polizei zu tun?
Eigentlich nicht.
- Eigentlich nicht?
Ist nichts mehr in den Taschen?
Sie können die Händen unten halten.
Was arbeiten Sie auf dem Bau?
- Ich bin Monteur.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Das wird nur eingezogen. Es gibt
keine Anzeige, nur einen Rapport.
Der wird nicht
der Jugendanwaltschaft geschickt.
Erfahren das meine Eltern?
- Wissen die Eltern nichts?
Nein.
Was wäre, wenn sie es erfahren
würden? Das wäre wohl nicht gut?
Das Vertrauen wäre null.
- Ja.
Sie sind ja schon 18.
- Ja, voll.
Eben, dann informieren wir
die Eltern nicht.
Bei Jugendlichen
müssen wir die Eltern informieren.
Können Sie hierhin stehen? Danke.
Ich fasse hinein und nehme es raus,
ja?
Haschisch, ja?
Sie sind noch minderjährig.
Das wird eingezogen.
- Ja, die Eltern wissen davon.
Sie wissen es?
- Ja.
Ich muss sie anrufen
und informieren,
dass es keine Anzeige gibt,
aber es sichergestellt wurde.
Informieren Sie sie zuerst,
ich rufe erst nächste Woche an.
Was macht ihr denn im Winter?
Nach draussen gehen.
- Im Winter ist es noch kälter.
Ja, aber dafür tragen wir ja Jacken,
wissen Sie.
Gut. Ja, eben.
Gehört die Dose einem von euch?
Die dort am Boden.
Danke.
Ein typischer Einsatz.
Bei Menschen mit Migrations-
hintergrund fällt mir oftmals auf,
dass es auf keinen Fall
die Familie erfahren darf.
Dort wäre es fast eine Schande,
wenn man sagen würde,
dass man Alkohol oder Cannabis
konsumiert.
Ist das nicht Sisyphusarbeit?
Na ja, Sisyphus ...
Es ist wichtig, dass wir das
Netzwerk der Jungen kennenlernen.
Wir sehen die Gesichter,
wer mit wem unterwegs ist.
Zu wissen,
wer mit wem in Kontakt ist,
kann uns helfen, Delikte und
schwerere Straftaten aufzuklären.
Auch wenn
nichts hängengeblieben wäre,
ist diese Sisyphusarbeit
für uns wichtig.
So bleiben wir auch
mit den Jungen in Kontakt.
Z.T. ergeben sich gute Gespräche -
auch unabhängig von der Kontrolle.
Sven ist nach Zürich gezogen.
Die Therapiestation Neuthal
musste er verlassen.
Es wurde Zeit für einen Wechsel.
Ich bin so weit,
meinen Weg Richtung Arbeitsstelle
und selbstständiges Wohnen zu gehen.
Ich habe ein Jahr Therapie
hinter mir.
Ich dachte,
dass ich da nie mehr rauskomme,
dass man mich
immer weitertherapieren muss.
Ich geniesse
das Gefühl von Freiheit.
Ich kann meine Energie rauslassen.
Neuthal war abgelegen
und tat mir gut,
aber die Stadt ist mehr das Zuhause,
das ich mir wünsche.
Ich hatte eine Woche Zeit,
um zu gehen.
Sie setzten mich unter Druck
in der Situation.
Es gab ein Riesending, weil ich
zweimal gegen die Regel verstiess,
dass man untereinander
keinen Sex haben darf.
Es ist halt schwierig,
wenn ständig Frauen da sind,
aber man nicht darf.
Da fehlt die Kontrolle
über sich selbst.
Wie geht es mit der Sucht?
Gut. Das Jahr Therapie
hat mir gutgetan.
Ich bin nicht rückfällig geworden.
Es geht mir recht gut.
Ich bin immer noch clean.
Ein ganzes Jahr clean?
- Ja.
Ja, voll.
Sven arbeitet in einem sozialen
Unternehmen in Zürich und beginnt,
sich in die Arbeitswelt
zu integrieren.
Wie hast du es geschafft,
so früh aufzustehen?
Muss ich um 5 Uhr
jetzt noch Fragen beantworten?
Ich bin kaputt.
Ich kann nicht frühmorgens
solche Fragen beant...
Es ist mir einfach etwas zu viel.
Allgemein.
Ja.
Es sind zwei Challenges, weisst du.
Einerseits arbeiten
und andererseits so tun,
als wäre alles easy.
Grüezi.
Wäre das alles?
- Ja.
Das macht 3 Fr.
Brauchen Sie den?
- Nein, danke.
Schönen Tag noch.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Anfangs war es recht schwierig.
Ich kapierte die Kasse nicht
und wusste nicht, wo was war.
Das gab ein Riesendurcheinander
und Stress.
Mir fiel eine Käsequiche zu Boden.
Das war mir so peinlich.
Ich wurde rot,
und die Kundin sah es.
Scheisse.
Du präsentierst etwas,
und dann fällt es zu Boden.
Dabei wolltest du es verkaufen.
Das ist ...
Und ein besonders gutes Erlebnis?
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ich weiss nicht. Keines bisher.
Schon hier zu arbeiten
ist ein besonderes Erlebnis.
Ich denke, hier zu arbeiten. Ja.
Ja, das ist Curry-Poulet.
- Das Vegi, gern.
11.50 Fr. zurück.
- Danke, schönen Tag.
Gleichfalls, ade.
Ihr könnt auch hier zahlen.
Zum Mitnehmen?
Sven, hast du
einen Kaffee rausgelassen?
Ja, Kafi creme.
Alles auf die gleiche Rechnung?
- Ja.
Er wollte ein Croissant.
* Gesprächsfetzen *
Was muss ich noch rauslassen?
Wie ist das, wenn
so viele Kunden auf einmal kommen?
Ein Druck.
Denn die Leute wollen nicht warten.
Wie gehst du damit um?
Ich glaube ruhig.
Ich versuche es.
So.
14 Fr. zurück.
- Danke.
Die Bratwurst ist 6.50 Fr., oder?
- Ja.
Zahlen Sie mit Karte?
Ich habe den Eindruck,
dass du dich wohlfühlst.
Ja, vor allem das Team gefällt mir.
Aus einer schlechten Situation
ist das jetzt der bestmögliche Ort.
Aber zwei.
- Zwei Bratwürste?
Ja. Geht das?
- Auf jeden Fall.
(Mann) Riecht gut, super.
Vielen Dank.
Was sind deine Ziele?
Eine Lehrstelle anfangen.
Eine finden.
Und eigenständiger
auf meinen Beinen stehen zu können,
von niemandem abhängig zu sein.
Ich denke, ich bin auf gutem Wege.
Ich brauche einfach noch etwas Zeit.
* Fliessende, sphärische Klänge *
Martin hofft
auf ein Leben ohne Psychopharmaka.
Nächsten Frühling werde ich
die Antidepressiva absetzen.
Momentan setze ich gerade
die Neuroleptika ab.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Mein Arzt sagte, es könnte sein,
dass ich ein Minimum
an Neuroleptika behalten muss.
Aber es sieht momentan gut aus.
Ich überlege mir, was ich tun kann,
um anderen zu helfen,
die das auch haben.
Martin möchte sich gern
im sozialen Bereich engagieren
und andere Jugendliche
vor schlechten Erfahrungen
mit Cannabis bewahren.
Allein durch die Aufklärung
könnte ich vielen,
wie mir in dieser Zeit, helfen.
Ich bereue nichts,
aber im Nachhinein denke ich:
Es wäre besser, wenn es für Junge
schwieriger wäre, an Gras zu kommen.
Hätte ich später
angefangen zu kiffen,
wäre bei mir vielleicht nie
diese Depersonalisierung
aufgetreten.
Ich glaube, am sinnvollsten ist es,
dass man das Thema
überhaupt offen anspricht.
Man soll offener darüber sprechen.
Es sollte in der Gesellschaft
anerkannter werden -
das kann schon viel bewirken.
Das finde ich auch wichtig.
Ein Thema so zu verschweigen
führt nur zu Negativem.
Es ist absolut kontraproduktiv.
Jede und jeder
muss selbst rausfinden,
was zu schlechten
oder guten Erfahrungen führt.
Würde mich ein 14-Jähriger fragen,
würde ich ihm sagen,
er solle nicht kiffen.
Aber man kann
gerade in dieser Phase nichts sagen.
Man muss sein eigenes Ding machen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Was findet ihr?
Sollte man die Prävention verstärken oder
den Besitz und Konsum stärker bestrafen?
Oder etwas ganz anderes:
Soll man Cannabis legalisieren
und wie den Alkohol regulieren, ähnlich wie
man das im Ausland auch schon versucht hat?
Was meint ihr dazu?
Schreibt eure offenen Fragen und
Meinungen in unsere Kommentare.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
L. Zbinden, M. Krähenbühl,
M. Hachen - 2021